[موسيقى] كانت
فكرتنا هي الحصول على المزيد من الطاقة باستخدام
نفس النوع من العناصر، دعنا نقول بهذه الطريقة،
وذلك لزيادة إمكانية استئجار
إنتاج الطاقة بنفس النوع من
العناصر، ويحاول حلنا أن يكون
مستقلاً عن تكنولوجيا
النماذج الكهروضوئية نفسها، لذا  يمكنك تركيب أي
نوع من النماذج الكهروضوئية التي تريدها، ما
يميزنا هو أنها يمكن أن
تتحرك خلال النهار وهذا يعني H
الحل الأول دعنا نقول الحلول المتطورة
التي لدينا في نظامنا يمكنك الحصول على ما
يلي من الشمس  شروق الشمس إلى
غروبها على جزء واحد بحيث يدور
أفقيًا لنفترض بهذه الطريقة وفي
حل نهائي أعلى لدينا حل آخر
يمكنك من خلاله تغيير ميل
النموذج الكهروضوئي طوال اليوم وهذا
يزيد من إنتاج النماذج الكهروضوئية نفسها
الطاقة التي  سيعتمد إنتاجها
على كمية النماذج الكهروضوئية
وقوة النماذج الكهروضوئية نفسها ومن
التركيب والتركيب الكهربائي
نفسه. ومن خلال دراساتنا،
يمكن أن تصل زيادة إنتاج نظام التتبع العائم إلى 30 أو 40٪
من  تركيب عادي أه مكافئ على الأرض
أو حتى التركيبات الأخرى الثابتة أه
التي هي
منشآت عائمة على الماء لقد جربناها وقمنا
بعمل طيارين في البرتغال لقد
صنعنا طيارين في هولندا على سبيل المثال
التي لديها شمس أقل والتي لدينا هنا
ولكن حلنا يمكن أن يكون  يتم تثبيتها في جميع أنحاء
العالم من الجانب الآخر،
ويمكن استخدام التكنولوجيا الخاصة بنا من قبل
السكان المحليين ومن خلال التنمية المحلية. والفكرة هي
أنه يمكننا تدريب الأشخاص
المحليين على التثبيت والتطوير
والصيانة بحيث تستمر المنصة في العمل
خلال 20 عامًا.  أكثر من 25 عامًا هو
العمر الذي نتوقعه من
منصاتنا، وستكون الطاقة الشمسية العائمة مهمة
جدًا جدًا في السنوات القليلة المقبلة،
وأعتقد أيضًا أن
كمية خزانات المياه الموجودة
لدينا والتي يتم استخدامها لإنتاج الطاقة
مثل الطاقة المائية  السدود على سبيل المثال أو البحيرات التي
لديك مساحة كبيرة يمكن استخدامها
لصيد الأسماك والري وأنك
لا تستخدم كل البحيرة نفسها
يمكن استخدام جزء منها لإنتاج الطاقة
التي من شأنها تقليل التبخر وأعتقد
حقًا ذلك  ستكون شركة protos وsalid
Float أحد مقدمي
التكنولوجيا التي ستساعد الناس في
الحصول على المزيد من الطاقة والمزيد من الطاقة النظيفة ولكن
أيضًا للحصول على مياه أفضل وتبخر أقل للمياه وتقليل
فقد المياه وما إلى
ذلك، لذلك أعتقد أنه سيكون كذلك
وضع جيد جدًا ومربح للجانبين
[الموسيقى]
للجميع